Hallo?
Hallo Leute, ich bin auch mal wieder am Start, mal ein Rollo zumachen.
Das ihr nicht alle durchs Fenster guckt, während ich am streamen bin.
So, ich war gerade noch mal auf dem Klo, ganz wichtige Info, ich weiß.
Ja, und was habe ich so verpasst?
Gab es irgendwelches Twitch Drama oder so in den letzten Tagen?
Ich habe nichts mitgekriegt Leute, ich bin immer noch ein bisschen krank mit meinem Hals.
Ich gehe morgen mal zum HNO Arzt, das habe ich mir schon überlegt.
Ich werde dann wieder Trick 17 ziehen und ruf an und sage, ich bezahle selbst.
Dann geht das immer sehr schnell.
Prime Sub, Dankeschön, 08max07.
Aber ich glaube, ich höre mich an wie immer.
Naja, mir tut immer noch ein bisschen was, wobei mir tut nicht der Hals weh.
Es ist vielleicht irgendwie entzündet oder so, keine Ahnung, ich musste echt mal langsam
was machen.
Habt es jetzt seit 4 Wochen oder so, irgendwann ist es ja auch mal gut.
Eins kann ich euch sagen Leute, was ihr nicht machen dürft ist, wenn ihr irgendwas habt,
sei es Halsschmerzen, Kopfschmerzen, was auch immer, ihr dürft nicht dem Internet
danach suchen.
Ihr habt, ihr habt von Kehlkopfkrebs bis Gehirntumor, ihr habt alles.
Das kannst du komplett vergessen, guckt, ich meine natürlich könnt ihr im Internet
gucken, es ist immer noch sinnvoll, das mit dem abzugleichen, was dein Arzt sagt oder
so.
Aber sucht nicht zu sehr rum.
Zum Beispiel, wenn ich sage, irgendwie, ich muss mich öfters reuspern und husten und
so, das ist alles.
Wie gesagt von Lungenkrebs bis Kehlkopf, Tumor ist alles, kann alles sein.
Da macht man sich komplett verrückt.
Dr. Google sagt Schwanger, ja, außeredischer Parasit, du bist immer kurz vorm abkratzen
eigentlich, wenn es nach Google geht.
Was ja nicht grundsätzlich falsch ist, muss man sagen, es ist ja schon Symptome, aber
wir sind alle zum größten Teil unter 50 und wenn ihr euch mal die Verteilung der Krankheiten
anguckt, die meisten gehen erst ab 50 langsam hoch und ab 70 dann richtig hoch.
Die Chance, dass man mit unter 40 oder unter 50 super krasses Zeug hat, ist sehr gering.
Er ist wie bei der Corona-Impfung, da kannst du im Zweifelsfall auch dran sterben, was
aber halt äußerst unwahrscheinlich ist.
Moin Leute, so, ich habe nichts vor, ich wollte einfach mal wieder Stream anmachen,
dass ich euch hier nicht so lange alleine da sitzen lasse.
Ich habe die letzten paar Monate so viele Videos gemacht, um so oft gestreamt und jetzt
quasi vier Wochen gar nicht, das kann ja nicht sein.
Außerdem finde ich das entspannend, das ist echt was, was sich geändert hat.
Ich kann mich noch dran erinnern, die ersten Streams, die ich gemacht habe, fand ich mega
anstrengend.
Da habe ich ja noch ein bisschen BDO mit Fabian gespielt, ich fand das richtig anstrengend.
Die ersten paar Streams, also das erste halbe Jahr oder so, ich dachte mir so, was erzählst
du denn und was machst du, da kannst du keine Pause machen beim Reden und da musst du immer
irgendwas sagen.
Was ja Schwachsinn ist, ich sage ja selbst, selbst wenn ich einfach meinen Kopf ausschalte,
rede ich mehr oder weniger den ganzen Stream durchgängig, das war voll anstrengend.
Mittlerweile ist es genau das Gegenteil, das Einzige, was mich anstrengend ist, es geht
mir ein bisschen auf die Stimme und ein bisschen auf den Hals, wenn ich zu sehr schwätze, aber
ansonsten finde ich Streamen tatsächlich echt entspannend.
Vor allem, wenn es so ein sinnlost Stream ist wie heute, wo wir nicht großartig was machen,
außer uns über ein paar aktuelle Dinge zu unterhalten oder sonst wie.
Ja, wo wir gerade beim Thema aktuelle Dinge sind, Leute, ich habe mir ein richtig nice
neues Heimautomatisierungsprojekt ausgedacht und zwar, ich habe Rauchmelder in fast jedem
Raum.
Im Bad habe ich keine Rauchmelder, aber ich habe beispielsweise dem Arbeitszimmer Rauchmelder,
Flur Rauchmelder, Schlafzimmer Rauchmelder, Flur unten Rauchmelder, Schlafzimmer unten
Rauchmelder, sowas.
So und ich habe mir ein cooles neues Projekt ausgedacht, inspiriert, inspiriert durch ein
YouTube Video, was ich gesehen habe und zwar habe ich mir jetzt gekauft, also ich habe
diese Rauchmelder hier, i650, ganz schön passt und die normalen, die ersten gehen aber
schon kaputt, die haben so eine Batterie drin, dass sie 10 Jahre halten, so und die ersten
sind aber schon kaputt gegangen, deswegen habe ich mir jetzt die hier bestellt, zum
Testen erstmal ein, so ein i650RF, das Gute ist, dass die Halterungen an der Decke passen
mit denen.
So und was man da bekommt ist, das ist eigentlich eine richtig coole Geschichte, was der Typ
in dem YouTube Video gezeigt hat, was man dabei bekommt ist, man bekommt den Rauchmelder,
man bekommt ein Funkmodul, weiß ich ob man das hier in diesem Video drin sieht, ist gut,
aber super, dass ich das uselessste Video aller Zeiten habe, ja es gibt ein Funkmodul,
das klipst man im Endeffekt einfach nur rein in diesen Rauchmelder und dann funkt er auf
868 Mhz und dann habe ich mir das hier dazu gekauft, das ist eigentlich nicht dafür gedacht,
da bin ich gleich gleich dabei, ne ne ne das stimmt nicht, das stimmt nicht, also das kann
ich so nicht unterschreiben, ich wohne seit 2013 hier in dem Haus und jetzt, jetzt ist
letztens erst in meinem Schlafzimmer der erste Melder kaputt gegangen und ich meine ja, 2013
bis Ende 2021, das sind keine wirklich 10 Jahre, aber damit kann ich leben, damit, also
mit der Dauer kann ich, kann ich leben, moin Michael 50 Billionen, so zumindest habe ich
mir den jetzt gekauft und ein i413, das ist ein Empfänger für diese Rauchmelder, so und
von der Idee her ist es jetzt so, eigentlich ist das gedacht, dass man das an eine Alarmanlage
bzw. an eine Hausbrandmeldeanlage oder sowas anschließt und Moment, was ich jetzt mache
ist folgendes, da drinne ist im Prinzip einfach nur eine ganz normale Platine, an der du an
Relays Zeug anschließen kannst, was du willst, das heißt von der Idee her, ich perre, wobei
ich kann, ich kann euch mal das Video zeigen, was mich dazu inspiriert hat, Shelley Smoke,
das Video hat mich dazu inspiriert, wir gucken es jetzt nicht, wir gucken uns den Aufbau
an, by the way macht, für Shelley Sachen macht er wirklich gute Videos, ja, so also das Video
hat mich dazu inspiriert, so sieht das von innen aus und von der Idee her ist das super
easy anzuschließen, man braucht diesen Shelley gar nicht, ich habe jetzt einen ESP D1 Mini
genommen und habe hier einfach verkabelt, ich habe die billige Variante gemacht, ich habe
einfach hier alles auf das Ground drauf geschraubt, drei Kabel und gut ist, verkabelt, das Dumme
ist nur, also von der Idee her wird es dann so funktionieren, hier gibt es einmal einen
Ausgang, wenn Batterie von den Meldern kaputt geht, hier gibt es einen Ausgang, wenn Alarm
ausgelöst wird, hier gibt es einen Ausgang, wenn CO2 Alarm ausgelöst wird und hiervon
kann man, das sind ganz normale Relays, die kann man abgreifen mit jedem x-beliebigen
Controller, mit jedem x-beliebigen GPIO, Raspberry Pi, was auch immer und sich das an seine Heimautomatisierung
schicken lassen, soweit, von der Idee, ja, netter Ross, Dankeschön für den huge massive
Subscription, so, das Problem ist jetzt nur, übersteuere ich heute ein bisschen, nee oder,
muss ich mal mal anhören, Test, Test, Test, bin ich heute am übersteuern Leute, was habe
ich eben gesagt, was habe ich eben gesagt, das Problem ist nur, dass bla bla bla bla
und so und bla und so, mal kurz anhören, das Problem ist nur, dass bla bla bla bla und
so und bla und so, ich höre mich an wie immer oder, ist eigentlich kein Unterschied,
der Husten fehlt, ja ey, ich habe gerade ein bisschen Salz, nicht Salz, Salz, wie heißt
das, Lösung, inhaliert, danach ist es immer besser, ich sag euch mal, mein Hals ist mega
im Arsch, genau und so habe ich das bei mir auch angeschlossen, das einzige Problem ist
nur, das ist kaputt, das Relay ist kaputt bei mir, das Relay, das Relay für Fire ist
kaputt, das merke ich daran, weil das Relay für Fehler funktioniert und das Relay für
Fire ist im Arsch, ich habe alles abgestöpselt und habe nur hier mein Messgerät dran gemacht
und man kann, wenn man das hier überbrückt, kann man den Testalarm auslösen, das Relay
schaltet einfach nicht, das hört man hier auch, das klickt ja auch, die Relays hörst
ja auch, so und jetzt schicke ich das zurück und viel Neues haben wir funktioniert, so
das ist das, das ist nice, da kann ich meine Rauchmelder nämlich endlich mal an mein Smart
Home anbinden, dass ich mir auch, wenn es brennt oder so eine Message schicken lassen
so weit die Idee, ah ja und der nächste ganz gute Nebeneffekt ist, dass die Rauchmelder
miteinander gekoppelt sind, das heißt, wenn einer unten im Flur angeht, höre ich dann
oben auch bei mir klingeln, ja die sind untereinander verbunden, das ist jetzt auch nicht der Fall,
weil ich ja die ohne Funk habe, also das ist insgesamt eigentlich schon ganz nice, oder
um nicht zu sagen, um nicht zu sagen, wenn es dann funktioniert, so viel die Idee, was
ist das hier, die haben aber nicht so gute Bewertungen, außerdem passen die nicht in
meine Deckenhalterung, die ich jetzt aktuell habe, nicht zu empfehlen Serienstreuern, exzellent,
naja wie dem auch sei, ja das bastle ich gerade nebenbei, um mich ein bisschen vor meinem
Hals abzulenken, tja ansonsten, ich überlege gerade, habe ich irgendwie spannende, ach
ja wisst ihr was ich gesehen habe, guckt mal hier, hat einer auf Discord gepostet, hast
du einen Tipp, wo man MikroTik-Router kaufen kann, es gibt viele Versionen, welche reicht
für den privaten Haushalt, wo du die kaufen kannst, bei Amazon zum Beispiel, oder bei
Park Geizhals, oder ist die Frage, welchen du kaufen willst, oder welchen du kaufen sollst,
weil welchen, das kann ich dir nicht sagen, da musst du ja halt sagen, was du haben willst,
das ist sonst ein bisschen schwierig, nicht Salzsäure, Wasser mit Salz, Wasser mit Salz
ist vielleicht nicht ganz so schlimm wie Salzsäure, ja welcher würde reichen, was willst du machen,
ich meine das ist sehr schwierig zu beantworten, willst du 10 Gigabit, willst du kein 10 Gigabit,
willst du 2,5 Gigabit, willst du deinen DSL-Moder anschließen oder nicht, was ich nicht machen
würde, aber man weiß ja nie, ja das muss man schon wissen, ja übrigens wisst ihr was
ich mitbekomme, aber vorhin, weil es jemand auf dem Discord geschrieben hat, in Vue CLI,
das ist das bis vor ein paar Wochen bevorzugte Tool um neue Vue.js Anwendungen anzulegen,
dort ist eine Abhängigkeit drinne zu diesem Paket, Node IPC und wisst ihr was die Programmierer
von Node IPC gemacht haben, die haben mit ihrer Software einen Check eingebaut, ob du
eine russische oder eine weißrussische externe IP hast, wenn ja löscht deine Festplatte,
was natürlich auf der einen Seite irgendwie als Protestaktion verstanden werden kann,
da kann man natürlich von halten was man will, ich meine das ist ihr Projekt, ja wenn
die es für richtig halten, egal ob ich das jetzt für gut oder schlecht halte, ich finde
es von der Aussagekraft ja vielleicht nicht schlecht, aber es gibt einen Grund warum ich
es wirklich schlecht finde ist, dass sowas zerstört das Vertrauen in so Projekte, ganz
ehrlich das ist natürlich schlimm und mag vielleicht aus ihrer Sicht auch gerechtfertigt
sein, gerade wenn sie da irgendwie persönlich davon betroffen sind, aber wenn ich so ein
Projekt dann verwende weiß ich nicht ob morgen nicht was anderes drin ist, also ich weiß
nicht, also das finde ich äußerst fragwürdig, achja kennt jemand einen unmanaged access
point mit POE, du meinst der sich über POE betreiben lässt, ja irgendeinen TP Link, irgendeinen
billig TP Link, guckst du einfach bei Amazon, TP Link, POE, BAM, achso das sind Switche,
Access Point, Access Points, POE, gibt es da nichts von TP Link, boah was denn das, sieht
aus wie zerklirrendes Kissen, ja sowas in der Richtung, es gibt es doch bestimmt, also
ich kenne aber keinen muss ich dazu sagen, boah was das, oh 1KS, was haben wir denn hier
für Ausgeburt in der Hölle offen, wann gibt es das 40 Gigabit Upgrade, ähm ich überlege
gerade ob es da ein realistisches Zeitfenster für gibt, also ich meine ich habe ja noch
nicht mal ordentlich 10 Gigabit, na wobei doch 10 Gigabit habe ich jetzt mittlerweile
ordentlich, aber es ist halt aktuell eher so, ich wüsste gar nicht was ich 40 Gigabit
irgendwie benutzen sollte, 40 Gigabit kriegst du vielleicht, vielleicht mit einer super
geilen PCI Express SSD voll oder so, aber was willst du denn da machen, ich weiß nicht,
du hast direkt LWL bis an den Rechner, nö, nö, nö habe ich nicht, ich habe, also LWL
ist für die Leute nicht, wir sind Lichtwellenleiter, das ist quasi das, das was umgangssprachlich
unter Glasfaser läuft, ähm ne habe ich nicht bis an den Rechner, hätte ich machen können,
ich habe, ich habe, ich habe welche hier, auch die passenden Module, aber mein Mainboard
hat ein Onboard 10G, AJ45 Stecker und dementsprechend ganz normales Kupferkabel und die Switche
und das NAS intern und sowas, das habe ich zum größten Teil über Direct Attached SFP
plus Kupferkabel gemacht, ich habe aktuell kein Glasfaserkabel im Einsatz irgendwo, ich
hatte den alten Server, den habe ich bei Glasfaser und Modul angeschlossen, aber ich glaube
ich habe nur Direct Attached Kabel aktuell und normale Kupferkabel, guck mal die China
Chinesen sind am Start bei Simplicissimus, das gucken wir uns heute nicht an, das ist
immer so dramatisch, wenn Vira das alles betont.
Ich habe mir aus der Arbeit auch zwei, was, was hast du dir aus der Arbeit, 2x10GR45,
Module oder was?
Bei Kabel geht ja jedes exbeliebige Kabel mit RJ45 Stecker, ach Module, ja das, also
wenn die noch welche übrig hätten auf der Arbeit, würde ich auch welche nehmen, weil
Module kosten sagen wir mal 50-60€ aufwärts und PC, ach PC Express Karten, wähä, warte
mal, das hat ja mit PC Express Karten nichts zu tun, ach du hast, du hast Netzwerkkarten
mitgenommen, nicht Module, du hast Netzwerkkarten mitgenommen, ach so, ja, ja, klar, man muss
sich mal überlegen, 10 Gigabit ist im Enterprise Umfeld schon eigentlich out, die schmeißen
die Hardware davon ja schon weg und da kann man, wenn es erlaubt ist, immer mal was abgreifen.
Ja ansonsten, ich überlege gerade, ach ja, ach ja, chat, chat, ich brauche mal eure Hilfe,
bald darf Chico auf meine Terrasse, also ich habe ja, also das in dem Haus hier, in dem
Haus hier haben wir es ja so, also du hast, Haus, Erdgeschoss, Keller, erster Stock, Dachgeschoss
und dann hast du einen Hof mit Stall, Garage und dann hinten, hinten einen Garten, so und
sowohl Hoftor als auch Eingang zum Garten sind eigentlich mit einem relativ undurchlässigen
und hohen Zaun zu, dass die Katze nicht drüber kann, aber ich traue meiner Katze nicht, deswegen,
deswegen habe ich mir gedacht, Chico ist nämlich, ich muss mal wissen, Chico ist eine reine
Hauskatze, war sie bisher immer, war sie bisher immer und ist sie bei mir bis jetzt, wie gesagt
ich habe die ja erst seit 3 Jahren oder so, vorher war die ja woanders, wurde ja im Tierheim
abgegeben, ich habe mir jetzt überlegt, diesen Sommer darf sie raus und da will ich
ein Netz an die Seite von der Terrasse machen, also Terrasse ist im Endeffekt Eingangstür,
dann kommt man auf die Terrasse, dann geht es runter in den Hof und dann kann man hinten
in den Garten oder in den Garage oder in den Stall oder so, so und ich habe mir jetzt was
bestellt und zwar gibt es bei denen so Netze, nicht Netzgarn, Netze, extreme Netze, es gibt
zumindest Netze für Terrassen und Balkons und sowas und ich bin zu dumm, guckt mal vielleicht
hat da irgendjemand Ahnung von, ich habe mir so einen Seil bestellt, also die Idee ist,
ich mache zwischen der Wand vom Stall und zwischen meiner Hauswand so einen Stahlseil
und da drüber mache ich dann die, mache ich das Netz und das Netz unten beschwer ich
halt mit Steinen und das kann ich dann auch zur Seite schieben, dass man die Treppe hoch
und runter kann oder ich ziehe es dann wieder hinter, wenn die Katz rausgeht, was auch immer,
hat jemand eine Ahnung, wie man sowas hier verwendet, ihr sagt jetzt Max, das ist ein
Stahlseil, da kann man nicht viel falsch machen, aber ich habe da ein Problem, dieses
Seil hat nur auf der einen Seite eine Schlaufe, auf der anderen Seite nicht, wie kriege ich
denn auf die andere Seite eine Schlaufe, guck mal das hat nur hier so eine Schlaufe und
auf der anderen Seite ist es einfach ein Stück Draht, hat irgendjemand sowas schonmal gemacht,
wie kriege ich auch eine Schlaufe, ich brauche ja, ich habe hier links einen Haken und rechts
einen Haken an der Wand, wie mache ich da eine Schlaufe, wie geht das, was mit dem kleinen
Teil auf der rechten Seite, das da, wie kriege ich denn damit, ach muss ich da das Kabel
so rein falten oder wie, wie nennt sich sowas denn, es geht gerade nichts, es geht sinnlos
Streamsorn bis ich Bett gehen muss und ich versuche gerade rauszufinden, wie ich das
Ding montieren kann, du machst einen Knoten, das glaube ich nicht, da war es als letzter
Schluss, weiß jemand, wie man das nennt, ich habe mal nach Stahlnetz, Längeneinstellung
oder sowas geguckt, da habe ich nichts gefunden, mit dem kleinen Teil, das ist ein Stahlseil,
eine Schlaufe machen und damit festschrauben, auf der anderen Seite bestimmt eine Mutter,
aha, also ok, das heißt, ich ziehe die andere Ende von dem Stahlseil hier durch, je nach
dem, wie viel Seil ich, also was weiß ich, wenn das Seil länger ist, als das was ich
brauche, dann schleife ich das quasi weiter durch, sodass das Seil ein bisschen kürzer
wird, mache dann am Ende eine Schlaufe rein und dann mache ich auf einem, wenn ich das
richtig verstanden habe, dann mache ich auf einem der beiden Seiten, hänge ich das, also
das hänge ich in den Haken, das hänge ich in das Seil und damit spanne ich das dann
an oder, ich habe sowas noch nie gemacht, ja, ja das mache ich, das mache ich, da habe
ich schon dran gedacht, auf der einen Seite ist es kein Problem, da ist nämlich ein Zaun,
da kann ich das durchziehen, auf der Seite vom Haus muss ich gucken, da werde ich wahrscheinlich
ein paar kleine Haken noch an jemanden machen, so ähnlich wie das hier, ach so funktioniert
das, Fifehead, also mal abgesehen davon, von diesem Metall, das ist da nicht drin, ich
mache das da rein, so und dann kann ich das hier beliebig lang durchziehen oder und dann
mache ich damit kürzer, ah, guck mal der Chat, der Chat weiß wieder, Chat ist einfach
massiv, wahnsinnig, ultra high IQ, FliBi, danke für den Sub, MrHarmank, danke für
den Sub, 8 Monate Alper Subscription, nice und den Rest vom Seil halt abschneiden, ob
ich da mit meinem großen Knibex Seitenschneider durchkomme, eher nicht oder, locker, Leute
das ist ziemlich dick, das ist 3mm Stahlseil, da komme ich nicht mit dem Seitenschneider
durch oder, das glaube ich nett, also ich rede, ich rede, so ein Ding hier, ne ne ne
größerer, größerer ist das, größerer, sowas da, so ein großer ist das, echt, echt,
ok, ach guck mal da ist ja sogar ein Bild davon, alter ich bin manchmal pepega, guck
mal die haben auf ihrer Seite sogar ein Bild davon, wie man das macht, hätte ich mir das
mal angeguckt, dann wäre ich jetzt schlauer gewesen, heute hat auch auf der Arbeit einer
geschrieben, Max du musst endlich mal meine Mail lesen, ich habe ihn 5 mal angeschrieben
so nach dem Motto, Passwort geht nicht, welcher Username muss ich nehmen, was muss ich dahinter
für eine Domain schreiben, jetzt geht das mit dem Popup nicht, aber Max guck doch mal
in meine Mails, habe ich alles in der Mail geschrieben, ich habe den irgendwie 10 mal
gefragt, dabei hat er es im Vorfeld, aber ich lese prinzipiell eigentlich keine Mails
mehr, Mails lesen ist overrated, jebaited, outdated, wer liest da, seriously Leute, lest
ihr auf der Arbeit noch regelmäßig Mails, wer liest noch regelmäßig Mails, also ich
habe es mittlerweile so auf der Arbeit, dass ich einen Ordner habe, Mails die an mich gehen,
die kommen in eigenen Ordner, alles andere bleibt in der Inbox und selbst der Ordner
an mich, den lese ich kaum, also Mail geschrieben habe ich glaube ich schon seit einem Monat
nicht mehr oder so, ich schreibe äußerst wenig Mails und lese auch ungern Mails, gerade
in der aktuellen Zeit, wo alles über Teams geht, ok aber Dankeschön Chat, ihr seid wie
erwartet exquisite 5HRQ, ohne euch wüsste ich nicht wie ich der Katze morgen auf der
Terrasse ihr Netz montieren soll, exellent, gut, da wissen wir ja Bescheid, macht aber
einen Unterschied ob man inhouse unterwegs ist oder als Dienstleister, Leute Leute wisst
ihr was, ASMR Stream, ich muss jetzt mal ein bisschen leiser reden und mal ein bisschen
beruhigter reden und ich merke mir tut schon wieder der Hals weh, ich schrei immer übelst
rum wenn ich am Streamen bin, warum eigentlich, so huge excited, was, Anketten, nein ich habe
doch gesagt das ist für ein Netz, das die auf die Terrasse kann, ohne über den Zaun
zu springen und vom Auto überfahren zu werden, da kommt ein Netz drüber und dann kann die
Katze in, in, in Hof quasi bzw. auf die Terrasse, ja das ist auch sinnvoll, was, was jebaitet
uns denn, ey play cancel das ist mir sowas von egal, das juckt mich überhaupt nicht,
übrigens doch eine Sache, wisst ihr was für ein get emoji, was für ein wegweisendes emoji
seit dem letzten iOS Update verfügbar ist, es gibt jetzt endlich ein emote für fette
Männer, pepo fett, es gibt jetzt endlich einen fetten Kerl, also endlich haben die auch mal
einen, ich wüsste noch was ich suchen muss hier, ah hier, pepo fett, ich muss ja sagen,
der Apple emote sieht irgendwie verstörend aus und ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob das wirklich
ein schwangerer Mann sein sollte oder ob die es ursprünglich nicht fetter Mann nennen
wollten und sich gedacht haben, fetter Mann triggert schon wieder 30.000 Leute und deswegen
wird es schwanger, wobei es halt irgendwie wenig Sinn ergibt, dass es einen schwangeren
Mann im emote gibt, also fetter Mann ja, aber schwangerer Mann, ich mein in der heutigen
Zeit ist ja vieles möglich und nur weil du heute ein Kerl bist, musst du morgen nicht
ein Kerl sein, aber es gibt so ein paar Sachen, die gehen halt nicht, also egal wie sehr ich
Frau sein will, wächst mir keine Gebärmutter, das funktioniert halt einfach nicht, der hier
ist auch nicht, sondern nicht glücklich darüber, deswegen glaube ich, das sollte ursprünglich
eigentlich ein dicker Mann emote werden und dachten sich, dass werden zu viele Leute getriggert
und jetzt gibt es dicker Mann, die sollten eher Bracken durch Typical austauschen, ja
das könnte man auch machen, Typical äh äh Typical ähm nicht Mann, sondern äh irgendwie
Hacker Mann, Typical Hacker Hacker Mann, es gibt ja auch immer noch kein gescheites Hacker
Emote, auch Pregnant Person gibt es, na gut, dass es Pregnant Woman gibt, das ist mir
klar, warum gibt es Pregnant Person, das ist für Schwangere, die sich nicht als weiblich
identifizieren oder wie ist das, was auch immer, ok es gibt Dinge, die muss ich nicht
ganz nachvollziehen, stört ja im Endeffekt keinen, dass es die Emotes gibt, aber das
finde ich gut, dass es endlich Pepofat Emote gibt und das gibt es seit iOS 15.4 und ich
glaube 15.4 ist gestern rausgekommen oder, ja sorry, vor gestern, am Montag, seit dem
letzten iOS Update gibt es das, wisst ihr eigentlich, was es für ein Ultra Wildwuchs
ist bei Emojis, bei Color Emojis, das muss ich jetzt einfach mal ganz kurz erzählen,
weil sich da keiner drüber Gedanken macht, aber das ein unglaublich komplexes und bescheuertes
Thema mal wieder ist, also diese Emotes, dass die so aussehen, wie die aussehen, ist euch
ja bestimmt auch schon mal aufgefallen, dass zum Beispiel das normale Emote, dass das überall
anders aussieht, so und warum ist das so, weil die unterschiedliche Emoji Schriftarten
haben oder unterschiedliche Emoji Schriftarten, das ist aber noch nicht der Abfuck, weil der
eigentliche Code, also das Encoding, CodePoint nennt sich das bei Unicode, ist ja bei allem
die gleichen, also sprich, wahrgenommen, ich kopiere das jetzt, wenn ich das jetzt hier
rein mache, sieht das für Windows aus, wenn ich jetzt Steuerung C auf Twitter drücke,
sieht das nach Twitter-Emote aus, wie auch immer, aber der richtige Abfuck kommt bei
den Emoji-Fonds, irgendwie müssen ja dann diese CodePoints, also das, was ich hier copypasten
kann, ich copypaste ja nicht das Emoji, ich copypaste ja quasi das encodete Zeichen, was
dann mein Font-Renderer zu einem Colored Emoji macht, so das ist ja im Unicode-Standard definiert,
wir reden jetzt gar nicht von der Sache, ist es UTF-8, UTF-16, UTF-32, lassen wir mal außen
vor, letztendlich definiert ist das irgendwo im Unicode-Standard und was der riesen Abfuck
ist, was der riesen Abfuck ist, Emoji-Schriftarten gibt es mindestens, mindestens vier verschiedene
Standards, wie man in einer Schriftart Pub-Informationen und Colour Emojis speichern kann, weil, müsst
ihr euch mal vorstellen, eine Schriftart ist ja mal ursprünglich für sowas hier erfunden
worden, da war noch nichts mit irgendwelchen Emojis, geschweige denn irgendwelchen Colored
Sachen und auch Farbabstufung, es gibt mindestens vier verschiedene Standards für Colour Emojis,
es gibt einen von Microsoft, einen von Mozilla, einen von Apple und einen von Adobe, wenn
ich jetzt nicht ganz falsch bin, und das geht von, wir speichern PNGs, zu wir speichern
Vektor-Grafiken, zu wir haben mehrere Ebenen, die Overlaid werden, das ist abgrund tiefer
Abfuck Emoji-Schriftarten, deswegen sieht ja das hier zum Beispiel im Firefox auch anders
aus und das Firefox-Emoji, ne das ist unter Windows, ach unter Windows verwenden sie mittlerweile
den Windows-Renderer hier drinnen, wunderbar, weil die hatten mal eine ganze Zeit was eigenes,
Mozilla hat dieses komische Zeug hier, genau, so und das war eine Zeit lang so, dass das
Mozilla-Format im Firefox funktioniert hat, aber der Firefox nicht das Windows-Format
unterstützt hat und sie ihren eigenen Font-Renderer verwendet haben, denn nur das Mozilla-Format
kann nicht das Windows-Format, es ist schlimm, warte mal, Max, dann machst du ein Wiki für
Emojis, warum soll ich das machen, gibt's doch schon, so Emoji-Color-Standards, da gibt
es Color irgendwas, Font, es gibt SVG in OT, genau, das ist Vektor-Grafiken im normalen
Font, dann gibt es noch irgendwas von Adobe und dann gibt es Apple-Color-Emoji-Standard,
das ist das was nur Apple kann und sonst keiner, Leute, das ist wieder ein absolutes Minenfeld,
das ist einfach, also das ist jetzt ganz, ja ich sollte meine Stimme schon, das stimmt,
es ist wieder ganz eklig, was da für Auswüchse die letzten Jahre über entstanden sind, wusste
ich jetzt einfach mal los, wenn, also ganz ehrlich, es ist wieder grausam, übrigens
mal eine Frage an euch, wo wir gerade dabei sind, was ist euer Lieblings-Emoji-Font oder
sagt mir mal was euer Lieblings-Platform ist, wie die Emojis aussehen, Apple, ich muss
sagen meine Lieblings-Platform ist Twitter, ich mag Twitter am besten, Twitter oder die
alten Joy-Pixels, die alten Joy-Pixels waren auch gut, die neuen Joy-Pixels sind doof,
also ich mag tatsächlich den Twitter-Style mit Abstand am liebsten, den verwende ich
nämlich auch unter Linux, da gibt es extra 3-Emoji-Font, also ich mag, was ist denn das,
Monac-S-Emoji, das habe ich ja noch nie gesehen, ist das jetzt auch neu, Moment wir müssen
mal kurz checken, was im letzten Unicode Standard alles dabei gekommen ist, Monac-S, Leute,
was ist das, nee Monac-S, nicht Monac-S, Monac-S, was soll das überhaupt sein, Melting-Face,
Abstand am liebsten, die Emoji-Platform, also ich mag Twitter-Style oder ich mag, also
die alten Joy-Pixels waren auch gut, die alten, nicht die neuen, die neuen Joy-Pixels mag
ich nicht, die alten, die alten Joy-Pixels waren gut, was ich nicht, die hatten noch
bestimmt, haben die nicht noch eine alte Version drinnen, Joy-Pixels, die alten Joy-Pixels
waren gut, die neuen, die, die neuen, weiß nicht, konnte man hier nicht mal mehrere
Emoji-Versionen, ah hier, genau, die alten Joy-Pixels fand ich ganz gut, die neuen sind
nicht so meins, wie gesagt, Twitter, Twitter gefällt mir am besten, was gibt's denn, zeigt
mal her, Emoji-Version 14, was kam denn da, ups, ups, ups, ups, was kam denn da neues,
vielleicht sehen wir uns den Apple-Style an, changed, was, das wurde changed, warum, appearance
of face with hand over mouth to mehr consistent, wie sah das vorher aus bei Apple, ah, ok,
ich muss sagen, das neue ist besser, also was ist da zugekommen, new added, new, ok, melting
face, links, was ist das denn, ok, Commodores-Emoji sind am Start, Leute, gibt's jetzt saluting
face, dotted line face, wozu braucht man denn sowas, face holding back tears, ok, dann
gibt es Hand nach rechts, Hand nach unten, index finger and thumb crossed, ja gut, das
ist bestimmt so ne Geste, die gibt es auf der ganzen Welt und heißt was anderes, was
heißt das bei euch, wenn man Daumen und Zeigefinger reibt, bei mir heißt das Geld, für mich heißt
es Kohle, Geld, das ist K-Pop-Scheiß, warum ist das K-Pop-Scheiß, machen die da auch
sowas, das One Direction oder, ne, nicht One Direction, das ist ja kein K-Pop, One Direction
sind ja die Engländer glaube ich, ne, ok, dann gibt es hier Uncle Sam oder was auch
immer das sein soll, index pointing and view, ach guck mal, das ist, das ist ein Herz, Hand
shaking, Lippo beißen, ok, Krone, dann gibt's den fetten Mann oder offiziell der schwangere
Mann, wisst ihr, Leute, ich hatte letztens, ist das Shrek, ist das Shrek Emote, ne, toll,
ich hatte ja letztens eine Idee, was endlich mal eingef, nachdem ich dieses Emote gesehen
hab, dachte ich mir, es wird doch Zeit, guck mal Leute, wir haben jetzt Gender Modifier
im Unicode, wir haben Color, Skin Color Modifier im Unicode Standard drin, warum gibt es keine
Body Shape Modifier, warum kann ich nicht sagen, warum kann ich nicht sagen, man, people, wo
ist das denn, ja, man, ach ne, man, man, warum kann ich nicht sagen, warum kann ich nicht
sagen, man, man shrugging und dann ein Body Shape Modifier dahinter, dass es Pet Man Shrugging
ist, also, guck mal, wenn wir so viele Sachen, wenn wir so viele Sachen schon mittlerweile
im Unicode drin haben, warum gibt es keine Body Shape Modifier, ich mein, ich kann verstehen,
dass das ziemlich schwierig ist, designtechnisch umzusetzen, aber wenn wir doch jetzt schon,
wir haben Gender Modifier und wir haben Hauttonen Modifier, also man hat fast, fast alles, um
irgendwie alles in alles umzuwandeln, warum kein Body Shape Modifier, dann könnte ich
dann zum Beispiel könnte ich das Emote nehmen, plus, plus den, das ist ja schon, das ist
Person Shrugging, plus Joiner, plus Male Sign, plus Skin Tone Modifier, kann ich noch machen,
dann ist es dann keine Ahnung, White Man Shrugging und dann noch Joiner Fat, Fat Body Size Modifier
und dann BÄM und dann hättest du dann Fat White Male Shrugging da draus gemacht, das
ist das, was die Welt braucht und dann, ey, kannst du alles machen, könntest du alles
machen, ne, Bärte, jawoll, es sind keine Grenzen gesetzt, na Hautfarbe, Bartfarbe ist
relativ einfach, Bartfarbe könntest du mit Bart plus einem Farb Modifier machen, dann
könntest du nämlich einfach die Skin Tone Modifiers nehmen, ich mein, da kannst du zwar
keine roten Bart haben, aber, was auch immer, die haben doch sogar Color Modifier, gibt
es doch auch, oder, naja, wie dem auch sei, so viel zum Thema Emojis, Haarfarbe bin ich
mir gar nicht sicher, kann sein, ja, mit der Musik los, warum lachen da Leute im Hintergrund,
da wird nicht gelacht, warum geht los, lachen sie einfach im Hintergrund, Mensch, ja, das
bräuchte man als E-Mode, exakt, die Designer, die Designer drehen durch, nächstes Stream
Projekt, sowas kann, das bringt mir im Stream Projekt nix, das muss, das muss auf den Endgeräten
unterstützt werden, meine, ketzerische Frage, kann, kann Emacs mittlerweile Emojis, das
muss ich jetzt mal nachgucken, Emacs ist ein Text Editor, muss man nicht kennen, ich weiß
nur, dass das immer ein, ein richtiger Klaubens, Klaubenskrieg fast war, ob Emacs Emojis bekommen
soll oder nicht, ne, immer nur noch diesen Fake, das funktioniert nicht, das ist, das
ist Fake, der, der macht aus Zeichen Bilder, das funktioniert nicht richtig, what the fuck
ist das, funktioniert nicht, es gibt anscheinend immer noch keine, oh, oh, Leute, seit Ende
letztem Jahr, Ema hat es aber voll übersteuert, ich habe es direkt hier im Rechthor gehört,
oh, ja schaut mal da, Emacs 28 hat Color Emoji Support 5 Jahre oder so, nachdem es relevant
geworden ist, nice, gut verwendet überhaupt noch irgendjemand Emacs, ich habe es eine
Weile früher verwendet, aber spätestens seit Visual Studio Code quasi JavaScript erweiterbar
ist, das ist doch der größte Vorteil von Emacs eigentlich mit dahin, ey ist es ja im
Prinzip jetzt schon, du kannst, du hast so viele Kombinationen an Emojis, die Designer
müssen, müssen ausflippen, die Designer haben da bestimmt gar keinen Bock mehr drauf,
du wirfst ja keinen Schatten, weil du im Dunkeln sitzt die ganze Zeit oder, so Hacker
Man im Keller mit Hoodie auf, die müssen es einfach NFT mäßig machen, NFT mäßig
machen, du machst einfach 5 Grundtypen und der Rest geht über einen Random Generator
oder über so ein Kombinations Ding, easy, John Wayner danke für den Tag, ach Leute
ich habe den Subs wieder nicht nachgeguckt, ich war jetzt so am labern was Color Emojis
angeht, ich habe wieder die Hälfte übersehen, Creator Dashboard, danke schön für den Sub,
John Wayner und Filby, dich habe ich schon gesehen Freund, Paul was, danke für den
Subs, ja ansonsten sehr random gewesen jetzt mit den Emojis, gebe ich zu aber ist mir gerade
so eingefallen, mir liegt gerade ob ich das andere noch erzählen soll, Paul ist bei mir
auf der Arbeit, ich erzähle euch ja ab und zu mal immer so ein, entweder erzähle ich
euch einen Schwank aus meiner Jugend oder ich erzähle euch mal ein paar komische Sachen
auf der Arbeit, aber diese Woche hatten wir wieder was, da musste ich echt lachen, es
wird, ich muss das natürlich immer so ein bisschen on the fly anonymisieren, bei uns
überlegen sie gerade von einem Standort, also von einem gemieteten Rechenzentrum zum
anderen gemieteten Rechenzentrum ein paar Services umzuziehen, das ist ganz grob der
Rahmen und das planen die seit Mitte letzten Jahres, so und Anfang der Woche, jetzt halt
euch auf was, Anfang der Woche kam jemand zu uns und meinte so, ja wie sieht es denn
mit euren Tätigkeiten für den Standortumzug aus und da haben wir so gesagt, welche Tätigkeiten,
das hat keiner irgendwas gesagt und dann meinte der so irgendwie, ja aber bis Ende der Woche
sollen doch die ganzen Systeme schon aufgebaut sein und wir haben gesagt, ne da habe ich
nichts von gehört und dann meinte der allen Ernstes, ja dann habt ihr jetzt ja noch dreieinhalb
Tage Zeit, dreieinhalb Tage für 80 Stinger, alles klar, kein Problem machen wir mal nebenbei,
in dreieinhalb Tagen, so und jetzt passt, sorry nicht 80, 40, 40, 40, so das ist an sich kein
Ding 40 Systeme aufzubauen, das geht, das geht, aber der Hit war ja dann, der Hit war
ja dann, haben wir gesagt, ja gut, wenn das so ist, dann soll erstmal hier unser Chef
sagen, dass wir andere Sachen liegen lassen, liegen lassen sollen und dann nur noch das
aufbauen, so aber jetzt kam der Hit, jetzt kommt so ne typische, ich würd's euch sonst
gar nicht erzählen, jetzt kommt so ne typische Business Enterprise Geschichte, so dann hieß
das wir sollen anfangen und auf einmal dachte ich mir so, ich hatte irgendwie so die Eingebung,
ich hatte irgendwie so die Eingebung, hey fragst du mal, also die haben zu uns gesagt,
die haben zu uns gesagt, ja baut das mit höchster Priorität so schnell wie's geht, das ist
ein Auftrag von unserem Abteilungsdirektor, also quasi viel höher geht's nicht mehr,
so und dann, da hatte ich so die Eingabe und hab mir gedacht, Moment, Moment, die können
ja viel erzählen, wenn der Tag lang ist, achso und es wäre auch schon alles genehmigt oder
sonst was, ich geh mal zu unserem Change Management und frag die, was sie davon halten, dass wir
jetzt einfach in Netzen, an Standorten, wo auch teilweise produktive Services laufen,
da am Netz rumspielen und neue Kisten hinstellen und so und ich hab gesagt, ja Change Management,
das ist ja quasi von unserem Abteilungsdirektor angefragt, ist das aus eurer Sicht okay und
dann meint die auf einmal zu mir, nein Max, ihr dürft auf gar keinen Fall anfangen, nicht
diese Woche ist Vorstandssitzung, wenn da irgendwas kaputt geht, die drehen alle durch,
ihr dürft auf gar keinen Fall was machen, dann hab ich gesagt, ja aber wir haben doch
nur dreieinhalb Tage, wir haben noch nur dreieinhalb Tage, das aufzubauen, es ist egal, ihr dürft
auf keinen Fall irgendwas machen, bis grünes Licht ist, so und jetzt ratet mal, also das war,
Dienstag haben die uns das erzählt und wir hatten damals ja schon nur dreieinhalb Tage,
das aufzubauen und jetzt ratet mal, wann wir das okay bekommen haben, dass wir es denn jetzt
machen dürfen, also Dienstag, ich sag mal Dienstag 12 Uhr, Dienstag 12 Uhr habe ich gefragt,
ob das okay geht und die haben gesagt, sie kümmern sich darum, das okay einzuholen,
was meint ihr, wann wir das okay gekriegt haben? Der Freitag ist ja erst morgen, nein, Freitag,
das war die Woche, Freitag ist ja erst morgen, ne, wir haben das im Prinzip gar nicht bekommen,
wir haben es, es hat einen Tag gedauert, nächsten Tag 14 Uhr und auch nur, weil ich zwischenzeitlich
mal gefragt habe, ja Jungs, gibt es was neues und dann meinten die so zu mir, ja ja, ist
genehmigt und dann musste ich noch sagen, ja aber ihr sagt doch selbst, mündliche Aussagen
sind egal, ich brauche schriftlich quasi einen Change-Antrag, den darf ich für Immersion-Sachen
selber doch gar nicht machen, haben sie noch was zusammengeklickt, so zumindest, jetzt
kommt der Hit, es war genehmigt, alles gut, wir wollten anfangen und auf einmal gucken
wir uns so mal die Netzwerktechnik, die Sache an und stellen fest, ja Moment, die ganzen
Switch sind falsch konfiguriert, das ist überhaupt nicht im richtigen WLAN, hat das falsche Netz,
die können da keine Server aufbauen, selbst wenn wir Server aufbauen, die funktionieren
danach nicht, so und ja, das ist immer noch der aktuelle Stand, also wir haben nicht
ein System aufgebaut bisher, also wie gesagt, der Auftrag kam irgendwann hier und wir sollen
fertig sein bis da, also im Prinzip, wir können nichts machen aktuell und dann ist irgendeiner
der Planungsleuten, der Planungsleute ist dann zu unseren Infrastruktur-Leuten gegangen,
hat gesagt, ja jetzt, mach doch mal die Netzwerksachen und Switch richtig und dann meinten die Netzwerkleute,
ja also ab 25. können wir uns darum kümmern, das ist so ein geiler Planungsfail immer und
ich erzähl euch das, weil ich euch am Ende mal was fragen will jetzt, wir sind doch sicherlich
nicht die einzigen, wo solche Planungsfails eigentlich an der Tagesordnung sind oder,
das ist doch bei euch auch manchmal so, gibts zu, weil wenn wir echt die einzigen wären,
müsste ich mir Gedanken machen, aber ich glaube, das ist eigentlich normal mittlerweile
bei vielen, gerade umso größer der Laden und umso Business-Enterpreisiger es wirkt,
übrigens noch eine witzige Geschichte von Microsoft, ihr wisst ja der Microsoft Support
ist hochgradig useless, wenn man Tickets aufmacht, noch eine Geschichte von Microsoft Support,
ich hatte euch ja mal erzählt, dass wir seit einer ganzen Weile gezwungen werden und gezwungen
ist der richtige Satz, weil es möchte von uns keiner, auf allen Systemen inklusive allen
Linux-Systemen Windows Defender zu installieren, das ist kein Witz, das ist kein Witz, wir
werden gezwungen Windows Defender zu installieren, wie wird das enforced, naja gut, es gibt eine
Security-Richtlinie, dass das gemacht werden muss, so und jetzt ist, ich muss das immer
ein bisschen anonymisieren und jetzt ist vor 1-2 Tagen sind Sachen gecrashed, weil jetzt
haltet euch fest, der Windows Defender den kompletten Ram belegt hat und das sind fette
Kisten Leute, das sind richtig fette Kisten, also die Kisten, die wir noch haben im Rechenzentrum,
die noch nicht in der Cloud sind, das sind richtig fette Kisten, das geht von, das geht
bei 128 GB Ram los, das geht rauf bis 2 TB Ram und teilweise mehr, das ist richtig heftig
und der Windows Defender hat dafür gesorgt, dass ein paar Sachen crashen, weil der Ram
voll ist, zumindest daraufhin Ticket gemacht, also nicht ich, sondern ich habe es nur mitbekommen,
es wurde ein Ticket gemacht bei Microsoft und Microsoft sagt, nein, können wir euch
nicht helfen, weil ihr habt nicht die letzte Windows Defender Version, wisst ihr was wir
haben, wir haben die vorletzte Windows Defender Version, also es ist jetzt irgendwie Punkt
60, Punkt 140 oder so Version und wir haben 60, Punkt 139, also die unsere Version ist,
was weiß ich, eine Woche allen oder so und Microsoft hat gesagt, bevor ihr euch an uns
wenden könnt und Support bekommt, ihr müsst alles upgraden, also ich weiß nicht, also
dieser Support, ja eine Woche End of Life, stellt euch das mal vor, das muss man verkaufen
irgendwo, eine Woche End of Life, das ist so eine Rolling Version von Microsoft, ist schon
echt lächerlich man, übrigens zum Thema Log Files, der Windows Defender, das ist wirklich
absolute Kack Software, der loggt auf Systemen, wenn verdächtige Sachen passieren und schickt
das dann an irgendeinen Log Storage in Azure und eines Tages ruft mich ein Kollege auf
eine Arbeit so an und meint, Max guck mal hier, ich share mal kurz mein Screen, zeigt der
mir das so und meint er so, sag mal Max ist das dein Passwort? Ja, das ist mein Passwort,
aber es war zum Glück nicht das Passwort von meinem Hauptbenutzer Account, das Ding hat
einfach mein Passwort gelockt, mitten im Log stand mein Passwort drin, das muss man sich
mal vorstellen, so eine Kack Software man, das ist absolute Hypercrap ist das wirklich,
ich glaube ihr wollt keinen Windows Defender haben, da braucht ihr keine russischen Hacker
dafür, Microsoft alleine reicht das schon, dann besser Kaspersky, da wird jetzt gewarnt
vor Kaspersky, da wird gewarnt, wir können ja mal Tipps abgeben, wie viele Server wir
schaffen morgen aufzubauen, ne schaffen wir ja gar nicht, weil die stellen ja erst zum
25. Also ich hab jetzt auf Heise gelesen, ich dachte mir das ist ein Witz, aber Kaspersky
sagt übrigens offiziell, sie haben noch nie mit der russischen Regierung zusammen gearbeitet,
die Sache ist halt die, das würde jeder sagen, selbst wenn er mit der russischen Regierung
zusammen arbeitet, oder meint ihr das sagt jemand groß, wenn du die fragst, also geht
bei denen wirklich irgendjemand davon aus, dass wenn du einen russischen Antivirenhersteller
fragst, sagt mal, arbeitet ihr mit der russischen Regierung zusammen, dass der dann sagt, ach
jetzt wo ihr fragt, ja klar machen wir das, wir haben nicht dran gedacht euch das zu sagen,
aber jetzt wo ihr fragt, jetzt natürlich, ganz was mit Schwachsinn, ja hab ich hier
bei Heise gelesen, Kaspersky, was ist denn mit Kaspersky, warte mal, ich weiß nicht,
was die hier geschrieben haben, Kaspersky, BSI waren von Kaspersky, siehe jetzt Antivirensoftware,
ja, Kaspersky hat jahrelang mit dem BSI, die haben wahrscheinlich mit mehr oder weniger
jedem zusammengearbeitet, es gab ja auch ein Paper, weiß nicht, ob man das in dem Zusammenhang
so nennt, aber ein Dokument von, fragt mich nicht, CIA, FBI, irgend so einem Kekona-3-Buchstaben-Ding,
gab es zum Anfang von diesem Konflikt in der Ukraine, gab es, also noch bevor die Russen
angegriffen haben, gab es ein Dokument, wo quasi gewarnt wurde vor Angriffen von russischen
Hackern und die Sicherheitslücken, die da drin standen, da dachte ich mir auch so, wahrscheinlich
hat das weniger was mit russischen Hackern zu tun, sondern die haben einfach ein Best
of ihre eigenen Dinger genommen, die sie gerne verwenden, um andere anzugreifen und haben
sich wahrscheinlich gedacht, ey, den Scheiß haben wir vor drei Jahren verwendet, das werden
die Russen bestimmt auch verwenden, haben das einfach mal in so ein Paper reingehauen,
da standen Dinger drinne, Leute, ich muss mal gucken, ob ich das jetzt finde, da standen
Dinger drin, ist ja aber auch egal, Outlook-Sachen von 2017 oder irgendwie sowas und Shitrix-Sachen
von 2016 und sowas, da hab ich mir auch gedacht, wenn das jetzt noch einer ungepatcht betreibt,
dann hat er schon längst Probleme, lange bevor irgendwelche russischen Hacker anrücken.
Wie ist eigentlich so euer Eindruck?
Ich weiß, wir haben hier sehr viele IT-Interessierte, es wurde ja am Anfang ein Riesenwind gemacht
von Panik, also auch öffentlich, vor russischen Cyber-Angriffen, jetzt Ukraine-Krieg oder generell
jetzt durch die Russen, da wurde mega Panik geschoben, mal ganz im Ernst, also so wirklich
wahnsinnig viel ist jetzt da nicht gewesen, oder?
Also das hält sich doch alles stark in Grenzen, also es gibt kaum Meldungen darüber, dass
hier irgendwelche Angriffe und wahrscheinlich sind das Angriffe, die sie gegeben hätte,
auf irgendwelche deutschen Unternehmen versucht werden bzw. vielleicht sogar erfolgreich
sind, es gibt immer mal wieder was, aber ansonsten, also im Vergleich zu dem Panik, also als das
losging in der Ukraine, da hast du ja das Gefühl gehabt, die Russen haben irgendwie quasi 50
Millionen Hacker, die nur drauf warten, alles auf der Welt anzulegen, ja, die Russen selber
kriegen es ja fast schon fast noch mehr ab als umgedreht, was Computer-Security-Sachen
angeht, aber es ist, also entweder sagt einfach keiner was, wenn er betroffen war, aber ansonsten,
also es ist null mit dem vergleichbar, wie das am Anfang hochgehyped wurde, wo du gedacht
hast, jetzt kommt gleich aus jedem Gulli kommt ein russischer Hacker mit seinem Laptop raus
quasi, es ist im Prinzip genauso wie vorher, die meisten Angriffe kamen, also gerade diese
meisten random, wir versuchen bei alle Passwörter durch und sowas, die meisten Sachen kamen
doch früher auch schon aus Russland oder aus China, ja oder den üblichen Verdächtigen,
BPN in den Iran oder so, ging auch gut, aber ansonsten, viel hat sich da auch nicht anders
aus, also viel verändert, viel verändert hat sich da nichts, naja, ich hoffe auch, dass
dann, ja wie gesagt, ich hoffe auch, dass da nichts mehr großartig kommt, weil sonst wollen
die Leute im Zweifelsfall auf der Arbeit noch, dass wir am Wochenende arbeiten müssen oder
sowas, weil die russischen Neckarmens unterwegs sind, nee nee, ich glaube es geht los, wieso
hast du so viele Tabs offen, Moment, ich habe nicht nur viele Tabs offen, ich habe sehr
viele Tabs offen, ich habe zwei Browser auf mit Tabs und wenn ich meine VM starte, dann
habe ich dort auch nochmal 40 Tabs offen, oh nee, die VM ist abgekackt, nee, die VM läuft,
aber die ist nicht auf dem Browser, was hat das mit dem Lidl Tab auf sich, eine Zigbee
Steckdosenleiste, die ich mal ausprobieren wollte, aber nie bestellt habe, genauso wie
mit dem Ikea Tab, im Ikea Tab hat irgendjemand letztens gesagt, Ikea hat ja das Gaming Möbel,
das war mir so nicht klar, dass Ikea jetzt Gaming Möbel hat, nee nee, ich mag Tabs,
man hat genug Tabs, wenn man den Text nicht mehr lesen kann, dann ist es gar nicht gut,
eine Stunde spielt kein Stream richtig, ja wie gesagt, ich sage nicht, dass es gar nichts
gab, es kommt schon immer mal wieder was, aber es ist jetzt bei weitem nicht das Riesending,
was am Anfang herbeigeredet wurde, mein armer Desktop, warum, der Desktop ist doch, das
ist halt ein Ordner und in diesem Ordner sind halt ganz viele Sachen drin, mein Ordner hat
vom Namen her was ordentliches, aber das heißt ja nicht, dass es in einem Ordner alles ordentlich
sein muss, ach jetzt ein bisschen, jawoll, genau, genau der, wusste gar nicht, dass ich
den als Emote drinne hab, oder ist das dein Personal Emote, was ist das Thema vom neuen
Video, ich hab tatsächlich 5-6 Sachen schon, auch mit Text, ich baue mir Textdokumente,
wo ich da reinschreibe, was ich sagen will, aber solange mir der Hals weh tut, habe ich
wenig Motivation gerade aufzunehmen, ja hab ich, und ich hab eine richtig lange Liste
mit Ideen, ohne dass ich jetzt konkret da schon ein bisschen was zu geschrieben hab,
also Videoinhalte und Ideen hab ich tatsächlich genug, ja aber echt so, ok, du meinst das
Ding hier von Lidl, ja das hat mir der Chat empfohlen und ich wollte das ja auch mal ausprobieren,
weil es immer weniger Steckdosen gibt, die Tasmota flashbar sind, und da ist so eine
Zigbee Steckdose was naheliegendes und das wird ja auch dann in Zukunft, wird es das
weitergeben, ja, wird es das
weitergeben wenn Meta 2030 kommt, ja Meta ist ja unten drunter auch quasi unter anderem
Zigbee, Seawave wird ein bisschen Probleme bekommen, Leute ich merke gerade, ich übersteuere
ein bisschen, das liegt daran, ich hab hier einen neuen Pop-Schutz, das hört ihr nicht
so krass, weil ich das hier limitiert hab, aber man hört es daran, ich hörs bei mir
auf dem Ohr, das liegt daran, ich hab einen neuen Pop-Schutz, ich hab mir nämlich aus
einem Autoschwamm und einem Kabelbinder einen neuen Pop-Schutz, also Teppichmesser, Schwamm
fürs Auto, Kabelbinder, hab ich mir einen Pop-Schutz aus dem Schwamm rausgeschnitten,
hab über das Mikrofon drüber gezogen, hab mit dem Kabelbinder zusammen gezogen, das
ist besser das Ding hier, besser als der offizielle Pop-Schutz vom Headset Mikro, ich mein es
sieht ein bisschen kacke aus, ich hab jetzt ein grau-schwarzes Headset, also ich hab hier
so ein Ding, ich hab die erste Ausgabe, first gen hab ich, das da, ich hab so ein grau-schwarzes
Headset und ich hab einen gelben Pop-Schutz dran, aber wen interessiert die Optik, was
für eine Soundkarte hast du, äh, onboard, ach Moment, du spielst ja so, ne ne, also
ich hab ne onboard Soundkarte, aber die hab ich mit, die hab ich per optischem Kabel
mit meinem Audiointerface verboten, als Audiointerface hab ich das da, als Audiointerface hab ich
das da, so und da gehen auch die Mikros drüber, das reicht aus fürs Headset, ne, für das
Headset hab ich noch einen anderen kleinen Mix-Amp, aber es geht alles an das Audiointerface,
ich habe eine Vue-Beautify-Web-App, die ich gerne, oh, dann hast du jetzt auch, dann hast
du jetzt auch, ähm, die, wann hast du zuletzt, wann hast du zuletzt NPM-Update da drin gemacht
oder NPM-Install oder sowas, dann interessiert dich bestimmt das da, die haben nämlich in
einer Dependency von Vue CLI, haben die, also das ist, eine Dependency von Vue CLI, ist
quasi eine, wie wir das in ein paar Videos sagen, Schadware drinne, die guckt ob du eine
russische Public-IP hast oder eine weißrussische Public-IP und dann löscht seine Platte.
So, was war jetzt aber die eigentliche Frage, ähm, ich habe eine Vue-Beautify-Web-App,
die ich gerne easy auf meinem Windows-Ordner aus surfen, sowas wie Exe im Projektfolger,
da kann ich jetzt nicht mit, ach du hast eine Web, du brauchst einfach, du musst einfach
quasi deine Index-HTML ausliefern im Endeffekt, äh, wenn, also das kannst du mit jeder x-beliebigen
Kiste, die Python drauf installiert hat, machen, da kannst du nämlich einfach sagen, falls
du, ne, aber das ist Windows, ne, das ist Windows, dann, dann nicht, äh, du bräuchst
jetzt irgendeinen Ad-hoc-Web-Server-Ding, pff, weiß ich nicht, was es da für Windows
gibt, gibt sicherlich 30 Millionen NPM-Packages für, also wenn du einen Python-Interpreter
hast, ist das ziemlich easy, das ist eine Zeile, das damit zu starten, ach ja, das ist ganz
gut hier, die Seite, guck mal, also was ich meine, ist das hier, also wenn du, wenn du
einen Python-Interpreter drauf hast, ist das mega simple, dann führst du das aus und der
surft einfach alles im aktuellen Verzeichnis, wenn du Sachen wie Websocket-Support brauchst
und sowas, dann ist es glaub ich ein bisschen komplizierter, was gibt's denn sonst noch,
äh, Ruby, Ruby, im Endeffekt muss das für eine Lion sein, ach so, ja, dann liefer ihm
doch irgendwas mit, dann schicke ihm irgendwas, dann brauchst du irgendeine Echse, die du
ausführst und alles im aktuellen Verzeichnis surft, da fällt mir aber für Windows nix
hin, keine Ahnung, es gibt doch bestimmt irgendeine, ich meine, im Prinzip ist es, ist es eine
3-Zeilen-Dotnet-Anwendung, ja, die man auch als Echse verpacken kann, da gibt's bestimmt
was Fertiges für, hat nicht irgendjemand was gepostet, sogar vor eben gerade, irgendwas
mit Desktop, ach ne, Convert tut, ne, das ist was anderes, ne, ne, das, das, das willst
du ja nicht, du nutzt doch E3 unter Linux, ja, mach ich, Arch, by the way, benutze ich,
wobei ich weiß nicht, ob man als Manjaro-Benutzer sagen darf, ich benutze Arch, haben wir noch
nicht gesehen, es wird immer schlechter, Alter, es wird immer schlechter, wenn man denkt,
es kann nicht mal schlechter werden, dann kommt, dann kommt ein neuer Tag Battlefield
2242, Alter, haha, das war schlecht, guck mal, wisst ihr was auch das witzig ist, Weihnachten,
Weihnachten, guck mal, fucking Weihnachten, es, normalerweise gibt es bei Spielen zu Weihnachten
immer so Hup, ein, ein, ein Piek, aber hier gibt es zu Weihnachten ein Dip, das schafft
auch nur Battlefield, ähm, wo wir gerade dabei sind, was macht denn mein anderes Sorgen-Kind,
New World, Alter, unter 30.000 jetzt gefallen, so schlecht, so schlecht, das ist auch so
komplette Totgeburt, das Ding, man darf nicht vergessen, es wurde im November released, November
release, das Spiel ist kein halbes Jahr alt, also, ja, Origin weiß man die Spielzahlen
nicht, ja, du brauchst im Endeffekt irgendeinen Single-File-Web-Server, ne, du willst halt
einfach eine Exe anklicken, die einen Web-Server vom aktuellen Verzeichnis startet, da gibt
es garantiert was, mir fällt aber für Windows nichts ein, ansonsten, wie gesagt, irgendeine
ex-beliebische Dornett-Anwendung, fünf Zeilen, dann als Exe verpackt, wer ist das andere
Amazon, Lost Ark, ja gut, Lost, ne, Lost Ark ist ja nicht von Amazon, Lost Ark ist ja nur
von Amazon hier vertrieben, Lost Ark, dem geht's, glaub ich, ganz gut, hat natürlich
auch Einbrüche, was aber ja noch relativ normal ist, oh, ich weiß nicht, wie das mit
dem Endgame aussieht in Lost Ark, muss ich sagen, spielt jemand von euch Lost Ark, also
ist das ein MMO, was man theoretisch auch zwei, drei Jahre spielen könnte und trotzdem
was zu tun hat, dass das bei 1,3 Millionen jetzt innerhalb von einem Monat bei einem
MMO viele wegrennen ist, ja, ist jetzt nichts ungewöhnliches, wobei, ich mein, ein Drittel,
also quasi, die haben ja auch schon, wenn du so willst, zwei Drittel der Spieler verloren
jetzt, das ist natürlich schon heftig, aber gerade bei MMOs, aber Halo Infinite läuft
auch nicht so gut, Halo läuft auch nicht mal so gut, aber hier, das ist auch ziemlich
am abkacken, also es ist im Prinzip alles am abkacken, so von den, von manchen Hoffnungsträgern
des letzten Jahres, aber ich weiß, ich weiß, das sagt EA, ich kenne diese Geschichte mit,
Halo war so polish, deswegen haben die Leute lieber Halo gespielt als Battlefield, was
eine bescheuerte Ausrede, Alter, wirklich, das ist richtig hängen geblieben.
Wollen wir mal gucken, was Cyberpunk hat?
Es gibt Spiele, die will ich gar nicht anklicken, das Cyberpunk Sex Simulator, man sollte nicht
so sehr nach Sachen suchen, Hentai Cyberpunk, das beste Spiel ist immer noch, was mich höchst
verstört hat, über den Titel, das beste Spiel ist immer noch, der Chair Fucking Simulator,
das ist so gestört, Alter, was es alles gibt, das ist kein Witz, das ist ein offizielles
Game of Steam, der Chair Fucking Simulator, da werden die Chairs gefuckt, es gab sogar
ein Update für den Chair Fucking Simulator, so sieht das Gameplay dann aus am Ende, wollen
wir mal gucken, ob das auf Twitch schon mal irgendjemand gespielt hat, Chair, ne, es hat
noch niemand den Chair Fucking Simulator gespielt auf Twitch, mega Toss, da passiert ja nichts,
es sind Stühle, aber was sich alles gibt, so, was wollte ich, genau Cyberpunk wollte
jemand, dass ich gucke, naja, guck mal, es spielen mehr Leute Cyberpunk, also es spielen
mehr Leute Cyberpunk als Battlefield 2047 auf Steam, nicht schlecht, was, es gab einen
großen Patch, okay, naja, ja, ja klar, bei den ganzen Stats kommen auch die GOG Leute
drauf, es ist ja auch kein, bei Battlefield ist ja auch kein Origin drin, also du kannst
von ausgehen, dass die echten Spieler zahlen, naja, ich glaube eine Null dran hängen können
wir nicht, aber nimm es mal, mal 3 oder so auf dem PC, vielleicht, vielleicht, ja, so
sind wir so bei 7000 ungefähr, was halt immer noch lächerlich ist, die Leute finden doch
jetzt schon keine Server mehr, ohne Bots und Portal ist eh komplett dead, übrigens Leute,
wisst ihr, ähm, Moment, wisst ihr woran man merkt, dass immer mehr Gamer mittlerweile
im Berufsalltag bzw. in normalen Positionen angekommen sind, es hat jemand gepostet letztens
in einem Teams Channel, also nicht in einem Chat, sondern Teams Channel, hat gemeint hier,
System XY wird jetzt abgeschaltet, so und ich hab dann dieses Bild hier gepostet, Sekunde,
Copy Image, ich hab dann dieses, hallo, ich möchte, ich will was kopieren, ja, ich will
was kopieren, kann halt so schwierig sein, genau, ich hab dann dieses Image gepostet
in den Chat und hat Instant gleich Emotes Reactions bekommen, also sprich wir haben Leute
auf der Arbeit, die dieses Bild verstehen, wenn es darum geht, es wird was abgeschaltet,
das stimmt mich ja schon durchaus zuversichtlich, ja, tatsächlich, ja, das ist kein Bleeding
Edge Meme 2022, das ist schon so alt, das kann jeder schon mal mitbekommen haben, aber
dass die Leute es verstanden haben, das fand ich schon mal gut, da kommt Press F her, ja,
wobei Press F, der Original ist ja Press X, der allererste Screenshot, der so die Runde
gemacht hat, ist von der Xbox gewesen, Press X, aber das mit Press F to pay respects hat
sich da irgendwie mehr durchgesetzt, erstmal Keque, ich hab schon mal Poggers bei irgendeine
Abstimmung reingehauen, wir hatten mal eine Abstimmung, ich kenne das, wenn Leute Präsentationen
halten, dass die manchmal versuchen besonders interaktiv zu sein und zwischenzeitlich dann
so, ja, wir haben jetzt mal eine Umfrage gemacht, geht mal alle mit eurem Handy da drauf und
wählt was aus, so was machen und da hat mal einer bei uns die Umfrage, da ging es um
irgendwie Microsoft Azure oder sonst was, da hat einer die Umfrage gestartet, so nach
dem Motto, ja, was sind ihre Meinungen zur Cloud, da hab ich halt einfach mal instant
Poggers reingeschrieben, nicht wirklich, weil es in dem Fall besonders Poggers ist, sondern
einfach nur weil ich mal Poggers in einer offiziellen Umfrage auf der Arbeit sehen wollte
in irgendeinem Chat und es ist, er hat es sogar vorgelesen, hat gemeint, aha aha, Poggers,
ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob er wusste, was es bedeutet, aber er hat es ausgesprochen,
er hat es vorgelesen, aha aha, Poggers, ich sehe hier Poggers, er hat vorhin gesagt, ich
sehe hier Poggers und da habe ich gedacht, gut, hat sich ja schon gelohnt, ich glaube,
er wusste nicht, was es bedeutet, das fand ich halt witzig in der Präsentation, aha,
ich sehe hier Poggers, Stonks, ja, oh man, ja gut, also ich muss glaube ich echt mal
irgendwann Tabs zumachen, weil es ist so unübersichtlich, weil vor allem so viel unsinniges Zeug, warum
habe ich den Mailregex zum Beispiel noch offen, warum, also wer übrigens mal AFC-konform
E-Mail-Adressen-Regex matchen will, das ist der offizielle RFC-Regex dafür, warum auch
immer, wenn ich den so offen habe. Gibt es noch irgendwas Leute, ich habe noch eine Viertelstunde
Zeit, ich habe nichts geplant heute und ich habe mehr oder weniger meinen Pulver, was
ich so erzählen kann, glaube ich jetzt auch langsam verschossen, ich bleibe auch nicht
mal lange on nach 15 Minuten, also 15 Minuten bleibe ich erst noch on bis 22 Uhr, dann muss
ich meinen Hals schonen wieder. Meinung zu Steam auf Chromebooks, habe ich noch nie ausprobiert,
keine Ahnung, wusste ich gar nicht, dass es geht ehrlich gesagt, aber klar, ich meine,
das ist ein Linux, warum soll es nicht gehen. Wie gut der Support ist, keine Ahnung, warum
willst du dir ein Chromebook kaufen zum Spielen, ich glaube da gibt es besseres. Vielleicht,
achso, das ist jetzt neuester News oder? Achso, das habe ich nicht mitgekriegt. Die erste
Alfa für Chromebooks ist erschienen. Aha, Chromebooks, warum nicht? Ich meine, das ist
das beste was uns passieren kann, die vielleicht mal darauf hoffen, dass irgendwann man gescheit
unter Linux spielen kann, also ohne, dass man immer sich Gedanken machen muss und im Zweifelsfall
doch was nicht funktioniert, dass man irgendwann mal vielleicht ganz unbedenkt, ohne großartig
nachzudenken auch sagen kann, naja, gut neues Game, installiere ich mir, obwohl ich unter
Linux bin, also das ist das beste was Valve machen kann, die können ihr Kram einfach
nur verteilen und hoffen, dass es nach und nach mehr Userbase kriegt. Stromo ist es halt
kein Linux, ist es nicht? Doch, was soll es denn sonst sein, Windows ist es nicht, was
anderes gibt es nicht. Es kann doch nur, BSD wird es nicht sein, es kann doch nur Linux
oder Windows sein, Windows ist es nicht, es kann doch eigentlich nichts anderes sein.
Ja, ein Gentoo ist das sogar, ein Gentoo Leute, nicht mal Arch by the way, ein Gentoo. Ja,
das wurde aber noch zu Zeiten veröffentlicht, wo Google noch die krassen Hackermans hatte,
die haben gesagt, wir verwenden Gentoo dafür. Ich habe einen 3D Drucker, ich habe einen
3D Drucker, warum fragst du, ich habe einen 3D Drucker, druck damit nicht so viel, mal
ein paar Gehäuse oder sowas ab und zu, druck vielleicht 2-3 mal im Monat was. Gentoo.
Hast du schon das neue Chrome OS Flex getestet? Ne, ich habe kein Chromebook und ich wüsste
auch nicht, was ich mit Chrome OS machen soll, ehrlich gesagt. Ich meine, man kann sich
Chrome OS sicherlich in irgendeiner VM oder so installieren, wobei das reichlich sinnlos
ist. Das kannst du einstellen. Du meinst, die erste LED geht mal an, geht mal aus, flackert
ein bisschen, aber nur die allererste, so random gefühlt. Es gibt ein Setting dafür,
die erste LED zu überspringen. Musst du mal in den Settings gucken. Es gibt explizit für
diese Probleme mit der ersten LED gibt es ein Setting in WLED. Also wenn du WLED verwendest,
wahrscheinlich, oder? First LED. Randomly first LED turn screen. Ja, da gibt es Settings
für. Du kannst es einstellen, skip first oder sowas. Musst du mal in den Settings gucken,
gibt es was für. Du bist also nicht der einzige, der das Problem hat. Ich frage, weil er werft
das Gehäuse. Die meisten Sachen in Smartphones kannst du doch gar nicht 3D drucken. Gehäuse
für Technik Sachen willst du eigentlich auch nicht, gerade für Sachen, die du täglich
wirklich 3D drucken. Wenn ich für meinen ESP ein Gehäuse 3D drucke, ist das ein,
aber ich druck doch kein 3D Gehäuse für mein Steam Deck oder Smartphone. Und die Innereien
kannst du ja gar nicht 3D drucken. Ich meine, vielleicht lobenswert der Ansatz, aber ob
das nennenswert irgendwas bringt, ich habe da meine Zweifel. Du wirst jetzt nicht, was
man damit machen soll. Bad Good Time, Leute, ich werde müde. Ja, wenn es sonst nichts mehr
gibt, soll irgendjemand hosten? Von den kleinen Leuten. Top Cut, keiner da. Ja, kein Problem.
Was? Wen? Das Name sagt mir irgendwas. Schon mal irgendwo gelesen. Ach, das R, jetzt weiß
ich, wer das ist. Das ist der, den ich eine Weile mit Tanzverbot verwechselt habe. Weil
ich das überhaupt nicht verfolge, aber dabei sehen die sich noch nicht mal ähnlich. Ich
habe die Stelle als Werkstatt. Ach, bei Rolls Royce oder wo warst du der? Warst du der Rolls
Royce Bewerber? Nice. Und wann geht es los? Und bezahlen die was Gescheites oder bezahlen
nichts und wollen vollen Einsatz? Also ein bisschen was bezahlen werden sie ja. Also echt
ein bisschen. Bist du zufrieden mit dem, was sie was sie bezahlen? Na gut, Leute, dann
machen wir jetzt ab. Alles klar. Wir sehen uns bis denn. Macht's gut. CU. Ich bin weg.